foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to what's new
in business intelligence
I am so excited to be here with you
today in person after so many years of
not being in person and not only do we
get to walk through what's new in bi but
we get to do that in the world we now
live in which is being disrupted by
generative AI
my name is Kate Wright I'm a senior
product manager here at Google
responsible for business intelligence
and looker and I'll shortly be joined on
stage by Andrew Becker
from our product management team here at
looker who's going to give you some
Hands-On demos of what we're announcing
today
now what we're going to do is we're
going to walk through Google's data and
AI cloud and how looker fits into that
and then I'm going to tell you more
about some of the big improvements we've
made to looker this year Google's
complete the eye product
and then we're going to talk a little
bit about looker's unique trusted and
open platform
and then we're going to talk about all
things Ai and how we're continuing to
infuse intelligence into looker and
bring AI to the Forefront
let's go ahead and jump in
now first we've all made these
incredible investments in data and AI
because of the possibility and impact
for our businesses
we've all made a lot of investments in
our people upskilling them and in
products and services and Technology
like why we're here today
and of course in projects and programs
given the number of people in this room
I bet you represent thousands of
different projects in data and AI
but unfortunately what the data is
telling us is that it's still really
hard
to realize that value
in fact
68 percent of companies are unable to
realize measurable value from data
and if you think about how we work with
our business and show them impact if
they can't see the ROI we're probably
not doing what we can
but thankfully there's a light at the
end of the tunnel because we're at this
incredible inflection point with Gen AI
large models stand to disrupt Industries
to help us innovate and generate new
business value
and here's why
traditionally it took huge amounts of
resources to extract and manage complex
data sets resources that for some
companies were prohibitively expensive
but all of a sudden with large models we
have been able to publicly process
to process the world's publicly
available information
and give that to our business
I'm going to say that again process all
the world's publicly available audio
images and text and give that to our
business in these accessible
conversational natural interfaces
suddenly our business is working with
information in totally new ways and
large models is what we have to thank
for that
not only that but large models are great
at creating information they can
generate text they can generate images
and they can help us write code
I use large models to write my emails my
husband uses large models as he's
programming every day
in fact I don't think we have yet seen
the ways that our personal and
professional lives are going to be
changed and how we're going to use large
models every day
I've been challenging myself on how I
could potentially use gen AI in my
day-to-day
this year and every year I do a
scavenger hunt for my daughter at Easter
and because I want to be that kind of a
mum I create these very Charming little
rhyming Clues you know different hiding
spots throughout the house and this is
the sort of thing that is completely
maddening I hate it I'm terrible at it
and this year instead of spending
multiple hours and frustrated midnight
minutes
I used a large model
I went back and forth with it a few
times
probably took me about 20 minutes to
feed it the clues I needed to ask it to
create the Rhymes to give it a little
bit of charm
make it talk a little bit about bunnies
and suddenly I was done it totally
changed the way I did that really simple
task every year and this is what we are
going to see in our professional and our
personal lives
and of course that also applies to data
and Analytics
large models stand to help our business
users be able to access information in
really simple really accessible ways and
that's our Enterprise information
and of course gen AI stands to help us
and make our data professionals so much
more productive
Google's data and AI Cloud provides a
unified data Foundation across your
database AI analytics and business
intelligence workloads
now unfortunately
running governing and administrating
data and AI is hard
but Google makes that easier with
best-in-class capabilities through
products that are built to work well
together
our approach is multi-format it's
multi-storage and it's multi-engine and
it's built for Google scale
so you can apply and bring and unify all
your data and AI workloads to date
Google's data and AI cloud
simply and easily
and vertex AI is not just for your AI
projects
it's also for our products we're using
those same Foundation models to infuse
intelligent capabilities throughout
Google's data and AI cloud
including looker
now looker is Google's business
intelligence product
it provides our customers self-service
and visualization so you can explore you
can visualize data you can create
dashboards you can schedule and you can
set up alerts to stay on top of your
business on both governed and ad hoc
data
we also have a rich set of developer
tools
because our customers know
that insights go far beyond a dashboard
and they have put information into their
own applications for their customers
their processes and their workflows
looker is powering marketing activation
processes and customer call center
automation
now
all of looker's capabilities are built
on top of looker's trusted platform
looker's semantic model is unique in the
industry and it can power consistent
metrics for all your users on your cloud
data
so let's talk about why looker is great
for your data and AI needs
first
it's a complete bi product
from consumers to analysts and
Developers
it's all Cloud native and it's built on
Google's data and AI Club
secondly
looker has a trusted and open platform
looker ensures all users can confidently
take decisions because they can trust
that the data is consistent and up to
date
and because of our open platform
philosophy
looker plays in nicely with the other bi
and analytics tools that are part of
your own data strategy
and lastly looker is infused with
intelligence
we make it easier for consumers to
access find and use the information that
matters to them in their jobs
we make it easier for analysts to be
able to create reports visuals formulas
and we make it easier for your
developers to be able to create custom
visuals and semantic models and today
we're going to tell you how that works
now let's jump in to looker Google's
complete bi product
now bi is all about connecting users to
insights
and looker has a full range of
capabilities so that means those youth
insights can be delivered to users and
dashboards in reports they'll be
delivered to your customers in schedules
or even used in automated processes
at the heart of looker is our unique
semantic model
this allows you to encode the business
logic and the business metrics that are
required and important for you
your reusability
that means once you define a metric once
you can use it in every Upstream
dashboard report application and process
people see consistent results
and not only that but our in-database
architecture connects to any SQL
database
meaning you're always looking at the
latest up-to-date data
no reason to worry about managing
extracts and schedule data exports
now our modern bi experience provides
ways to explore to visualize and report
on data both represented in governed
trusted data and the ad hoc data we know
the business is going to use
looker provides visualization
capabilities and self-service on top of
governed data
looker Studio provides an ad hoc
analysis experience
and connected sheets for Looker gives
you a way to give your business a
spreadsheet Paradigm to work with the
data the way they need to
now of course we've learned in the last
few years that business intelligence is
so much more than dashboards
which is why looker is API first
our customers have built some phenomenal
kinds of data experiences on the apis of
looker they've learned how to monetize
their data how to create new product
lines new applications and new premium
tiers for their own customers using
insights and Analytics
and they've actually started infusing
the machine learning workflows that run
in their organization with the same
trusted data that is part of the looker
platform
and of course we know
that the users in your Workforce are
probably not always working in looker
which is why we have Integrations with
productivity Suites collaboration tools
and of course Partnerships with some of
the biggest data and AI products in the
market
now there are three big things I want to
make sure you know huge improvements
we've made to looker this year and I'm
going to start with looker Google Cloud
Core
looker Google Cloud Core makes it really
simple for all our Google Cloud
customers to access and to run looker
because we've brought it right on to the
Google Cloud console
we've also added increased Enterprise
capabilities like customer managed
encryption Keys private IP vpcsc
and additional ways that you can manage
your instances you have additional
controls over maintenance Windows you
also have additional ways that you can
audit and analyze how people are using
looker
and lastly
because we're always striving for deeper
integration between our products we've
also released service agent connectivity
to bigquery
and now introduced Google IAM support
look our Google Cloud Core is generally
available
it's accessible on the Google Cloud
console today you can try it and of
course you can use it
now the next big thing I want to tell
you about is looker Studio Pro
last year at this time we introduced
looker studio and liquor Studio Pro to
the looker family
looker studio is an ad hoc analysis
experience with a familiar Google
interface
it connects over 800 data sources
including premium ads connectivity and
of course Lookers trusted semantic model
with looker Studio Pro you get all the
value of liquor studio and in addition
you get technical support you get
additional ways to manage and govern
your users and your content and ways to
reach your people on the go
with schedules alerts mobile and
integration with Google workspace
now
the last thing I want to tell you about
that we've done in 2023 for looker
it's connected sheets for looker
I have a feeling that in this room
there have been a lot of dashboards and
reports created over the years
and yet despite that I bet there's
always somebody in your business who
wants that data dumped into a
spreadsheet so they can work with it
offline yes
and of course what you don't want is for
them to go
play with that spreadsheet and email it
to a bunch of people because who knows
what's going to happen
we have recognized that here at looker
connected sheets for Looker gives people
a way to access Lookers trusted data in
a spreadsheet format so your users can
work with pivot tables formulas and
charts all on top of that trusted data
for Looker always being able to go back
and connect it to the platform
connected sheets for Looker is part of
Google Sheets
part of every edition of Google Sheets
including our free editions so if you
are a customer of looker your business
can use connected sheets for liquor
which is generally available today
now
we chose to highlight those three big
things
but rest assured we've done a lot in
we love to build things that our
customers are looking for and the team
has been hard at work
I can't go over each one of those right
now so thank you for taking pictures
but I did want to make a shout out
especially to our long time looker
customers to take a look at a few of
those features
first the advanced editor for
visualizations
you no longer are restricted to what's
in the box and ships with looker from a
visualization standpoint
I know that somebody in your business
really cares about the thickness and
shade of the line on the trend shirt
gives you the ability to open up that
configuration and gives you near
infinite possibilities when it comes to
how you're going to style and show your
data and visuals
we're also really excited about some of
the new customization features we've
shipped for our embedded customers
our customers run their own products on
looker and they want to show off their
product the way they want it
so we've shipped additional
customization around theming for
dashboards around scheduling and around
alerts this year
our customers appreciate that looker
gives them a complete bi product
that helps their users choose how they
want to work with data in these various
modalities
for example carbon Health has found
great benefit to drive significant
results by using connected sheets for
liquor
they were able to see significant
improvements in operating results in
just 30 days of rolling out connected
sheets for liquor
now let's talk about Lookers trusted and
open platform
Lookers trusted modeling layer provides
that single place to curate and govern
the metrics that matter most to your
business
this means that users see consistent
results whether they're in Connected
sheets for Looker or in an alert
or an output of a downstream process
coming from Lookers API
we want to ensure that you can use this
consistent trustworthy information in
your tools of choice and wherever your
users are consuming information
which is why we've opened up the looker
modeling layer and are working hard with
our partners to ensure this works with
your own analytics and business
intelligence tool strategy
that means the data that's inside
Lookers trusted platform does not have
to stay there
we are also working with our partners to
extend the capabilities of looker making
it more valuable for our shared
customers and I'm going to tell you a
few things about that today
first let's start with an update
to our visualization partners
I suspect your organizations have many
bi tools in the landscape raise your
hand if you have more than five bi tools
that you have to manage or that at least
are in the landscape
that's what I thought you know what's
funny is is right now the record is 18
for people I've met just so you know you
can probably feel like it's not too bad
but that said we recognize that this is
the world we're all living in most of
our customers have multiple bi tools in
the landscape they don't talk to each
other and you end up with business logic
kind of scattered wherever it makes it
much harder for users to be able to
trust the data they see
this is why we've developed Partnerships
with some of the leading vendors in the
space to make sure that looker plays
nicely and you can bring those trusted
metrics to where all your users work
I recently announced a partnership with
hotspot
soon you'll be able to use Lookers
trusted metrics in their search based
experience
now today
we are very excited to announce the much
awaited Tableau integration into preview
soon you're going to be able to use
tableau's familiar drag and drop
interface on top of looker's trusted
data
we are also excited to announce
General availability of our power bi
integration
oh come on
so you will be able to use Lookers
trusted data inside power bi
now we're also working to extend the
capabilities of looker with our partners
our partnership with sisu brings looker
customers the added benefits of easily
determining the root causes behind
changes in their business
so you can easily find the anomalies and
the outliers that are driving those
changes and sisu also helps you
understand what to analyze next
I personally love the way sisu helps you
understand why something is changing
we are very pleased to announce today
that our sisu and looker partnership
will be generally available this quarter
[Applause]
now let's talk about one of those
necessary evils of business intelligence
and that's data preparation
we spend a lot of our time
putting the data together connecting it
joining it aggregating it to the right
level cleaning it up
and we want to help our customers do
this more easily so today we are
announcing a new partnership with
alteryx bringing alteryx designer Cloud
to our looker customers to more easily
do data preparation on their data
starting with CSV and Excel files
now
the same openness
and flexibility is what has led
customers to Google Cloud
sound Commerce has built a platform a
data platform for retail companies using
bigquery and looker
retail companies are struggling with the
transition from brick and mortar to
digital as we all know
sound commerce's data platform has
helped accelerate those companies
transition towards e-commerce using the
power of Google cloud bigquery and
looker
all right are we all ready to talk about
AI
all right looker has been infused with
intelligence for a long time because
looker was born in the cloud
as cloud and AI have evolved so is
looker
our customers already use looker to
infuse insights into their own ML
workloads and of course the intelligent
capabilities that are already within
looker
but we're going to bring AI to the
Forefront of looker today
now
why does this matter
we expect most of our data professionals
to spend a lot of their time on tedious
and repetitive tasks and unfortunately
that keeps them really busy which means
when our business consumers want
information and answers it tends to take
a long time to turn that around
you also have this constant back and
forth Telephone Game communicating from
the business to the analysts on what is
actually needed
we believe we can simplify and
accelerate how people use information
with Gen AI which is here to help us
I want to tell you a little bit about
what is coming very soon to looker and
our looker customers
today we are introducing duet AI for
Looker it's like having an analyst right
in your pocket
[Applause]
now duet for AI for Looker helps
everybody
so it helps our consumers be able to
easily get information because they can
converse with looker to get answers that
are relevant for them
and once they have the information they
need they can easily share it with their
business
duet AI for Looker helps them get their
job done the analysts so so much faster
we're helping analysts generate visuals
reports and formulas
all using generative AI
and for our developers and our data
engineers
duet Ai and looker is going to help them
generate the code required to configure
custom visuals and to write lookaml
making it so much easier to define the
semantics that run your business
now I'm very excited to welcome onto the
stage Andrew Becker
from our product management team who's
going to be showing you these various
capabilities of duet AI inlooker
live now Andrew Escape
get that quicker
awesome should we see some demos
all right
so yeah our teams have been working
super hard and we're really excited to
show you all these cool new capabilities
so our first duet AI capability enables
you to have a conversation with your
data
so you can ask questions in natural
language and get back charts and tables
so it's really like having an analyst in
your pocket at all times
this is really about democratizing
access to data-driven insights it's
pretty good at handling even vague
requests and it can come back with some
options to clarify if necessary
so when you find what you're looking for
you can add those charts to your report
with one click
I'm going to go ahead and show you this
working in real code
so this is uh really a whole new way of
interacting with business intelligence
so we recognize that answering questions
and building reports really two
different use cases
business decision makers in particular
sometimes they just want to get to the
answers fast and the interface can be an
obstacle
so conversational queries makes
answering those data questions fast and
easy this means more people making
data-driven decisions with less time
spent on selecting fields and formatting
charts
so here we've added a little breakdown
of our top five categories let's go
ahead and try one more how about a
weekly sales trend for last quarter
so duet AI is going to come back and ask
to clarify if you meant orders created
shipped or delivered
and we'll get that answer and we'll get
that added to our report
all right automatic slide generation
so a long time ago a PM mentor of mine
told me you know you can have data
warehouses data lake houses all kinds of
data things but all data eventually
flows to slide decks
so how many hours has this group spent
building slide decks you know for
monthly reporting annual reporting
quarterly reporting so the second of our
consumer Focus capabilities automatic
slide generation does that for you we
want our users to spend their time
finding insights not building out slides
let's take a look
so your AI analysts will build Out full
presentation in Google Slides it's going
to take each chart from this report
and it's going to make a slide for each
and each slide will have natural
language bullet points summarizing the
chart
so these will call out Trends maximums
minimums differences all kinds of
different insights definitely a huge
Time Saver for anyone who does regular
reporting
all right
duet ai's report generation capability
builds upon the conversational queries
we saw earlier
so here you can have your AI analyst
create an entire report for you
we all know that building and styling
report can take much longer than finding
the data
report generation gives data
professionals a great start get a report
something that you can build on
so we'll start by entering a few
sentences about what you want in this
report
here we're asking for performance year
to date
you'll tell it any fields that you
definitely want to include and
generative AI will suggest the charts
that should be in this report and build
the full layout
you can choose some formatting and
styling options as well
this is a huge Time Saver for anyone
who's spending time building reports
manually
all right on to formula assistant
so looker studio power users will be
familiar with calculated fields
these can be pretty tricky to build
especially heavy duty formulas like case
statements I know I always have to check
the reference
I've been using this formula assistant
the capabilities in Duet AI for a few
weeks now whenever I need to find a
calculated field formula and it's pretty
awesome
let's try a couple formulas so we're
working on a brand performance report
let's try something easy let's do profit
margin
formula system takes care of that no
problem
let's go ahead and get that added to the
Chart here
and let's try something a little more
difficult let's do bucketing
profitability high and low
anything over five percent
formula assistant knows how to write
that case statement makes it super easy
look at that it added into the table
all right
Advanced visualization assistant
so visualization tools always have a
limited set of chart options and as Kate
mentioned it kind of always seems like
the one that you need is not the one
that you have
and power users can code custom viz but
what about the rest of us
so in looker we recently introduced this
Advanced viz config it's a Labs feature
make make our visualizations much more
flexible but it does require writing
code so now we're adding a natural
language assistant
this means infinite possibilities for
charts without code
there we go all right so we'll have duet
AI update this chart and I've got some
requirements we'd like to make one of
these a dashed line
go ahead and apply that and how about
making one of these series into a column
chart
super easy uh let's try highlighting Min
and Max
all right one last thing let's move that
Legend to the upper right
all with natural language
makes it super easy we're really excited
about this one
all right lastly
let's talk about the lookamal assistant
capabilities of duet Ai and looker
so we know it can be a hurdle to learn
lookamal and with generative AI we can
make that both easier and faster
so your AI analysts is going to help you
churn Out lookamal Rapid clip really get
to the value of looker modeling much
more quickly
let's take a look
so SQL Drive tables for example are
super helpful but can be challenging
especially for newer lookamal developers
with lookaml assistant there's no need
to remember the correct syntax how to
join tables
so this is really great for those times
when getting through a tricky part need
a little bit of help getting started
it's going to generate that look a mile
for us
so we cannot wait to get these
capabilities out to our users thank you
so much and back over to you Kate
time here
all right are we all excited about duet
Ai and looker
[Applause]
we are really confident that duet Ai and
looker is going to help everyone in your
organization work with data I mean
personally couldn't we all spend a
little less time formatting the data and
a little more time actually using it to
make decisions
confident High judgment decisions
powered by data
duet AI inlooker will be coming to
preview soon we encourage you to sign up
for our trusted tester program through
duet AI
and you'll get first hands-on experience
with duet Ai and looker
now
we wanted to give you a preview of all
the things we're doing around infusing
intelligence inside looker and this is
what's coming soon to our customers
be honest that this is just the
beginning of what it means to bring AI
to the Forefront of business
intelligence
I wanted to give you a sense of how
we're thinking about the problem
first
maybe highlighting the problem
the reality is that it's still the
minority of our Workforce that actually
has access to use data every day
and I'll tell you as somebody who's been
in this industry for a really long time
this number really hasn't changed
and this is why we're so excited about
the possibility of generative AI for
changing this game for us because of the
way that it's simplifying the way people
are using information
we believe that this kind of
consumerization of interfaces could be
what drives us to see more of our
Workforce meaningfully be able to use
data in their day-to-day jobs
so let me tell you a little bit about
where we're going with looker because of
course Google has always been on the
Forefront of AI and looker is no
different
we imagine a world where it's really
easy for everyone to just chat with
their business data
we want our users to feel like they
truly have that analyst in their pocket
that's always on never sleeping and
knows what they need
now the possibility of having more
people be able to get answers quickly
without always relying on a data
professional could be revolutionary
and not only that but once people have
the information they need we want to
help them share it with others
tell their stories with data in the
format for the Right audience at the
right time at the right moment
we can create powerful beautiful
impactful data stories
all with business intelligence with the
aid of generative AI
now I bet there's a few people in the
audience right now who are getting
butterflies in their stomach at the idea
of giving the keys to the kingdom to
their business
because there are a lot of challenges
with trust and data has to be accurate
we can't have our business making
decisions on data that can't be trusted
and this is why the trusted data found
in looker forms such an important
foundation for us not only now
but also going forward
we believe that we can solve these
challenges by not only having a
consistent set of information that is
semantically Rich inside the platform of
looker but also working to connect the
data professionals with the business
users in easy ways to ensure that you
really can give this kind of freedom and
power to the business
now I promise I won't make you literally
sit here and imagine it I'm going to
show you what this can look like
before I roll the video
I want you to just notice a couple of
things
I want you to notice how people are
working how easy it is to get access to
information and these kinds of
experiences
how people are working together to make
decisions because data has to be in the
supporting role people ultimately make
decisions together
and also how data professionals and
business users are able to work together
to ensure that everyone can trust how
the decisions are being taken
let's go ahead and let's roll the video
[Music]
the future of business intelligence is
instant and insightful watching over
your business able to alert you when it
really matters and guide you to
impactful decisions faster than ever
powered by the most important
information yours
answers at the ready an informed
always-on Analyst at your fingertips
where you work
foreign
for your entire business
collaborate live on data you see
together
talking with AI shouldn't just be a
one-on-one chat it should transform the
way you communicate and collaborate with
your entire team as you solve problems
together
[Music]
trust but verify
future of bi still relies on the
smartest machine the human making the
decisions reviewing the code and
approving the queries
approved
the future of bi is data access and
actions where you work empowering your
team with type ahead and documents and
answers in chat and presentations not
just in the bi tool
[Music]
thank you
we all know that in bi even the best and
most accurate data is not always enough
you need attention and credibility
generating beautiful reports and
infographics should be as simple as
clicking a button
[Music]
the data never stops because you never
stop
[Music]
the future of business intelligence will
help you take on the greatest business
challenges and make decisions faster
smarter better anywhere
[Music]
reimagine what your data can do
[Applause]
I hope you are also able to notice how
easy it was for people to really tell
their stories with data once they got
the answers they needed and also how
business intelligence can truly keep up
to the speed that your business is
changing and help you know what to do
next
now we are working very hard on making
it trivially easy for everyone to be
able to just chat with their business
data and feel like they have an
always-on
analyst working for them in their pocket
as you can see the future of bi at
Google cloud is very bright
now
between duet Ai and looker soon in
preview and where we are going with bi
we are confident that we're going to
help everyone be more successful with
data from your business users being able
to easily Converse and get the
information and answers they need
to your analysts being able to easily
get their job done and have more fun
doing it and of course for your
developers too
with this
I'm afraid we're coming to the end today
we have some work to go do as well
and I hope it was helpful to learn about
some of the huge improvements that have
come to looker this year Google's
complete bi product
I also hope you have a sense of how
Lookers trusted and open platform not
only forms the basis to make trustworthy
decisions today but also to form the
basis of intelligence going forward
and now I'm sure that you have a sense
of how we're bringing AI to the
Forefront of looker with duet Ai
inlooker and Beyond
we're going to make sure that your
customers our customers and you feel
like you can receive the impact you'd
like to on your data
thank you very much everybody who was
able to join us today I would love to
just draw your attention to a couple of
sessions if you have more interest in
business intelligence check out
analytics213 data monetization through
embedded analytics our colleague scander
is hosting this and he has helped so
many customers monetize their data in
all sorts of different ways if you want
to get a sense of what you can do with
looker take a look at analytics213
and I'll also make a shout out to our
Spotlight session 203 what's next for
data and AI that was run yesterday we're
also running it again on Thursday and
you can get a sense of how business
intelligence bigquery and everything in
that data in AI cloud is evolving
so thank you everyone for joining us
today
[Music]
foreign